oh hey house Cobras my name is Peter Pan
let's keep playing hard of dare Canaries
my shirt will change okay so here oh
great oh great we're over now what's
gonna kill us next I can't wait oh great
there's stuff everywhere just [ __ ]
stuff every [ __ ] where that took how
long two seconds three seconds four
seconds five [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you jump [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you Jim alright
[ __ ] you
alright alright alright [ __ ] all of
y'all Oh God and it [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
you and it [ __ ] everyone oh my [ __ ]
ah shoot every [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
well that was a lot [ __ ] easier than
then I did let's keep going hey hey hey
why am i shooting that way you think
you're real [ __ ] smart huh
[ __ ] you what are you gonna do with that
oh the button takes it down hey buddy
suck on this [ __ ] that's right now what
what do I do hot buttons how do they
work
this is another button it is
okay okay so it's time okay got it
yeah jumper jump around like a [ __ ]
dick okay we got to be fast if we're
gonna do this yeah jump over it now get
it oh thank god
oh my god this reminds me of the Aladin
level you know in the old Sega Aladin
game that was a great [ __ ] game not
this [ __ ] hard was it
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that's got to burn
my hands to climb on these alright it's
gotta burn my hands oh god more crabs I
love crabs I love every kind of crab I
just want to hug them all that's I bet
that slime [ __ ] me god I hate spiders
hey buddy how you doing I'm fine I
wanted that to happen
I am [ __ ] the dumbest [ __ ] I need
your support right now cuz clearly I am
sucking ass right now
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] was that jump
come here [ __ ]
oh my god he sucks ass oh he can come
through the screen Oh suck on that
titties [ __ ] out why was that so hard
alright now what well that wasn't too
bad was it
what the [ __ ] just happened what the
[ __ ] what the I'll thank God
oh they're sneaky there it is you want
what does he do he throws [ __ ] at me
what do i do then
I just have to go here and shoot him I'm
so [ __ ] dumb oh my god what the [ __ ]
oh god oh my god I did it
[ __ ] hell god dammit god dammit pros
this game plays from my emotions I don't
[ __ ] know how long I could take it
man don't jump too far alright don't
jump alright jump them thank you thank
you for doing the right thing in your
life for [ __ ] ones oh god no no no
you don't even give me one second to
breathe I don't even get a second to
breathe I don't get a second to feel
like I'm not a piece of [ __ ] I don't
even get a second Bam Bam Bam had a lamb
lamb lamb
oh yes should that direction you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that's how it's done ladies in
rows oh my god that was so easy
why didn't I not do it at effort time I
don't ever enough don't charge the
attack hey buddy
that's right got you oh my god alright
now what okay I'm gonna go this way
oh great crabs my favorite
oh my god can something not to try and
kill me
awesome this guy on [ __ ] drugs oh my
god I almost died again come on
[Music]
[ __ ] God [ __ ] and it hit me where
exactly mr. scientist where exactly on
top of my hand all that is great that is
fantastic I feel great I swear this part
it's gonna [ __ ] kill me oh my god
come at me come at me then come at me
then come at me then that's right the
[ __ ] is this oh so now we can go
underneath I suppose
great oh my god I will die tonight if I
[ __ ] is that oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
Oh three of lit fun vocaroo law oh yeah
yeah yeah another one another one
[ __ ] all of you
oh my god oh my god oh my god the skills
right [ __ ] now they fall into song
why did I commit to this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this game is a [ __ ] fraud this game
cost 9/11 I'm sure of it so Sat then
draw the big time at that yeah nah
forget yeah
nah baby don't touch me again I'm busy
playing games yeah that's right child
support services can go [ __ ] himself
okay all right I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
still in the game I will never play
myself so sat then what source at then
remember Lahore no Stella me la la la
huh willow holiday level whole hotel AHA
below olotele available at Aloha that's
kind of all the time although you have
lemon torta hell event that all around
touch mom limit F if you can't do dirt
for me
I love you I'd go but goddamn don't
touch me right now don't I don't want to
be touched I don't want to be touched
right now I don't want to be touched
right now alright I don't want to be I
don't want to be touched I don't want to
be touched for I don't want to be
touched right now hey I don't want to be
touched right now I don't want to I
don't want to be touched right now don't
touch don't touch me [ __ ]
Meredith suck my dick
[ __ ] oh my god I hate the crabs if I
was born a crab I would never crab again
cuz crabs aren't [ __ ] worth living
men ever a fun you're hot do no man
estan hey have you ever [ __ ] a crab
before hey men ever to still laugh it
down fun and bleep then don't charge the
attack all right you're not Charizard
and you will never be Charizard you're
not even good enough you're not even
good enough you're ain't no [ __ ] ash
you ain't no [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Clym why
my sweet child of its climbing then your
shirt is too low you should look stupid
okay oh god more crabs he's gonna come
and I got him right before he went for
my but I got him right before I never
forgot [ __ ] are you [ __ ] [ __ ] any
[ __ ] dick and my shoe is there and my
shoe is standard should've thought about
that before you [ __ ] [ __ ] array now
we just gotta make sure oh god they're
everywhere
mom mom they're in my hair mom hey
oh yeah jump nice move John jumping
there yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that's it
that's it baby girl y'all want to you
want you wanted some of the put a pike
pie and you got the pie and you didn't
eat the rest of it that's what happens
that's what happens when you don't
finish your pie man
that's right [ __ ] we're doing well I'm
very focused
I think we need to go down here why are
we have a unicorn what is this gonna do
that doesn't really help me does it was
I supposed to shoot it before I was
wasn't a oh my god
well back we go I guess [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
am i right oh do do hold a toast okay
okay here we go if we [ __ ] this game you
know what this game should be called hey
you know what if you [ __ ] up once hey
[ __ ] you that's what this game should be
called so big one then one two and now
it's safe to go got it
oh and then one two holy [ __ ] I almost
died I almost [ __ ] died Jesus did not
die for this all right now go go forth
my child oh god we got to go back we got
to go back Kate
we got to go back Kate we got to go back
Oh God one big one small small go and
this one is big one small small same
thing okay big one small small come on
yes okay we got this for us we got this
we got this we got this bros we got this
we got this
I don't wanna yes
Edgar's smelling his own fart right now
he farted B don't push it down that I
would [ __ ] suckle again how do I not
[ __ ] this up right up my ass it went it
went right up my ass I love it I know
how do we oh okay okay what [ __ ] you
game nay nay nay nay they're fun in the
Sun the heat
yeah blah first us ice this game it's
gonna be the end of me it's absolutely
[ __ ] ridiculous and now we go back
you go you go through so much effort so
much effort cheer up
hahaha that's funny I'm laughing on the
inside I'm laughing on the [ __ ]
inside if I die now I will kill myself
tonight
when Marzia comes back I'm gonna I'm
gonna shoot I'm gonna I'm gonna get
Edgar and I'm gonna let him I'm gonna
let him I'm gonna I'm gonna take Edgar
and I swear to God I will
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] I I'm so ready
to quit life right [ __ ] now
jump down [ __ ] jump down as [ __ ] so
Kat just get the stash
oh my god what is this [ __ ] [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me charger
[ __ ] me Jar Jerry
[Music]
just died just died
he's fine
I always knew jar-jar binks with
statements creature always what is this
can't they just fly me to the end of the
level can they fly me to the end of the
game please yeah thank thanks for thanks
for it thanks for putting me thanks for
putting me that thanks things thanks for
putting me deep thanks for putting me
down thanks for putting me down guys
thanks for putting me down thank you so
[ __ ] much buddy [ __ ] you game I swear
to god I can't [ __ ] - and it looks
like we're gonna have to end another
episode there but if you enjoyed please
leave a like and I'll see you bros in
the next video and as always stay
awesome